hey guys and welcome back to the lay
High open show the place where we have
some of the hottest conversations on the
entire internet so today we are talking
about Bitcoin and how it can become the
fastest cryptocurrency in the world for
sending money so joining me to have this
discussion is the CEO of tectum Russell
Shawn Russell welcome to the show how
are you today yeah very well how about
you Taylor great to be here yeah I'm
great thank you I'm so excited to have
this conversation especially because the
market is pumping right now Bitcoin is
pumping so it's gonna be brilliant so
before we get into all of this
I want to I want to focus on bitcoin
because there's just so many people who
think Bitcoin is great but they do
believe it has a lot of scaling issues
you know some say it's too expensive
it's too slow so Russell can you tell us
what tectum is and how you're solving
this problem with Bitcoin and
essentially just making it more
efficient
yeah absolutely that's a great Point
Leia and everybody's heard of the BTC
trilemma or the blockchain trilemma it's
the idea that PTC has great security and
it's got great privacy and
decentralization but the scalability is
the issue so tectum is our blockchain
it's a blockchain that we've been
developing for over six years and we've
got it to 1.3 million transactions and
we've got it set up so it can be in a
decentralized sense but the issue is of
course all the credibility all the
history that goes with Bitcoin makes it
such a strong currency or a
cryptocurrency so what we aim to do was
ensure that we could combine the two
make Bitcoin scalable on our blockchain
and essentially we came out with the
soft node and the soft note
aims to overcome all the problems of the
lightning Network that's the same we
followed the project very closely we
love the lightning network but we saw
some pitfalls but the idea of the soft
note is we can now make Bitcoin a lot
faster and a lot cheaper than it
currently is while still holding on to
the great security great
decentralization that comes with the
network
that's the thing isn't it because it's
always that trilemma security versus
decentralization when you're trying to
scale
um and actually yeah it's just it's just
so fascinating and this soft note I I'd
never heard of anything quite like this
before until obviously I came across
tectum so can you explain to me what is
a soft note yeah absolutely it is an
incredibly novel idea we don't know of
anybody in the industry doing something
like this so if you imagine a b2c wallet
layer yeah WTC what it holds Bitcoin but
we came up with a novel concept whereby
rather than trying to move the Bitcoin
as the lightning Network currently does
we've decided to move the ownership of
Bitcoin but to accomplish this of course
you've got to split Bitcoin up into
denominations and if you think back to
when first gold was assigned paper notes
or it was assigned a representation of
the notes people realized that gold was
not scalable you couldn't carry bullion
bars to go and buy a house you didn't
want to take that a certain distance so
you had to find a representation of the
goal and that's exactly what a soft note
is it's a serial number and a passcode
it represents a Bitcoin wallet and you
can then on our blockchain that's 1.3
million transactions be able to move
that representation about very quickly
and very cheaply so we do have an image
attached to our soft note and you can go
to the web page that connects to our
blockchain and see that imagery it's
great imagery but essentially it is just
a serial number and a passcode the gives
you access to those private keys of the
Bitcoin wallet that's been denominated
so it's such a such a different idea you
know because everybody's always building
that layer 2 scaling solution like the
lightning Network so I I want to get
more detail on this you you mentioned
that you are a fan of the lightning
Network and you know you you like what
they've done and you know you've been
following it for a long time but but how
is lightning different than to the soft
note
yeah great question later and the way we
see it is the way they set up the
lightning network with their initial
stage was completely right they looked
rather to move Bitcoin but move a
representation of the Bitcoin so you've
got on the lightning Network a ledger
and Records any transactions that go
between you and the recipient but they
didn't go as far as we thought they
should have gone we believe that they
should have taken this the whole way and
just moved the ownership of Bitcoin so
as things currently stand you've got the
limitation of they've done it on a
multi-sig wallet basis so you've got the
limitation of the sender and the
recipient it's very hard to keep a trust
the system and a trust the system just
means that you don't have to trust the
third party or centralized Authority
it's quite complex to keep that and Take
It Outside one send them one recipient
without then compromising
decentralization so as things currently
stand with the lightning Network you've
either got to stay in that Channel or if
you use routing you've then got to bring
in a watchtower system so what we find
climbing with the lightning network is
people are settling a lot more
frequently than they had anticipated
because people don't want to open these
routing channels they want to get back
into Bitcoin but so trusted
and we said we saw this play out in El
Salvador I don't know how much you track
that layer but the lightning network was
the underlying system of the cheaper
flight wallet out in El Salvador and it
was set to transform the industry make
the national currency of El Salvador
Bitcoin but the problem was as soon as
you go into McDonald's your lightning
Network transaction works perfectly but
if you want to switch over to KFC then
you've either got to go through a
routing Channel which was taking a long
time to open or you had to settle on the
Bitcoin native Network and I think of
the latest that layer was 70 of el
salvadorians no longer trust the
lightning Network and BTC 80 of
companies are refusing to accept it now
for us if they had gone the full way and
just continued to move the ownership of
Bitcoin that problem wouldn't have
happened because when you're moving just
the ownership of Bitcoin you're not
limited to multi-sig wallet you're not
limited to a channel
wow that's actually one issue that I
personally have with the lightning
network is oh it's opening all these
multiple channels
um I I don't like that I think it's a
lot I think it's difficult
um but in terms of moving the ownership
of Bitcoin I find that's so fascinating
how safe is that like how do you what
are you doing you're not moving the
Bitcoin but you're moving the private
Keys the sea phrase like you're moving
the the wallet like how do you do that
and how safe is that yeah exactly there
so we're moving the private Keys the
private keys of course have never been
hacked I think the latest estimate said
that it would take Millions upon
millions of years for a quantum computer
to have if I accuse The Brute Force hack
but that's when you don't even have the
public keys I mean you've got to have
the public keys to experiment with that
so because it's such a secure system the
way we've approached it is we actually
encrypt those private keys on our
blockchain and then the passcode that
you get with your serial number gives
you access to those private keys if you
ever want to burn your soft note but the
idea is because you're not limited to
this channel like you are with the
lightning Network as soon as we've
developed the mainstream adoption that
we're looking for people won't ever burn
their soft note because they know they
have access to that it's a little bit
like saying did anybody ever go back and
get their gold and split it up when they
have the notes to represent it they
didn't have to because the value was
there so as long as we can create that
value which we believe we have done with
such a secure system people stay within
the software knowing that they can
always get access to those private keys
if they ever want to get their Bitcoin
out
so how simple is it to use a soft note
and to access it for just a normal
Bitcoin holder you know like a mum or a
dad how easy is it to to actually use a
soft note because I know by the way I
know the lightning Network a lot of
people struggle to use that if they're
not super technical absolutely and this
is one of the most incredible things
about the softener because it's an image
it can turn into a web page the web page
is just based on the serial number you
could go to cash dot softener right now
put in your serial number and you have
access to that softener that soft note
lets you see the Bitcoin that's backing
it on the Bitcoin Ledger through
blockchain.com or any of those major
websites a list of Bitcoin ledger so you
know the finance is always there you're
never going to incur the issues that we
had with FTX not knowing that the
backing is there but it's so simple to
use because it's just a web page as long
as you hold on to that passcode then you
will always have access to that softener
and the fascinating thing is Leia
because we've taken it off the
blockchain environment you can then send
ended over WhatsApp Messenger you can
send it over Facebook messenger and it
is no longer confound to these
constraints that every single
cryptocurrency that we're aware of is at
the moment whereby you have to be in a
web free environment you have to be in a
blockchain environment
I think that's so important
um because like I said with the
lightning Network it's so complicated
for the average person
and if you're if you're changing if
you're I guess expanding the ecosystem
to web 2 to you know things like
WhatsApp and and just sort of instant
messaging and you're able to you know
bring people in that way then it makes a
lot of sense but how how similar are you
to paper wallets because it does sort of
sound like that in terms of you know
having in terms of like moving the
ownership and being able to pass on the
private keys yeah absolutely it sounds
similar but there are basically no
similarities in this sense yes you can
print a soft note out but that's as far
as it goes you print out your paper
wallet you've got your public key and
you've got your private key there that
has so many security issues I think
there is a documentary done recently
about a CCTV surveillance system
actually picking up and reading the
private keys on one of these paper
wallets you won't take it anywhere you
can't read it you've got to ensure that
you're looking over your shoulders to
whoever's near you because they could
pick that up and so essentially our
private keys are never seen they're not
even seen by the blockchain the nodes
can't see them because they're encrypted
and the only person that can decrypt
them is the person who has access to
that passcode who then Burns that soft
note so perhaps functionally you may
deem them to be similar because you can
print them out you can hold them exactly
exactly but outside of that that yeah
the security is perfectly different
I'm interested to get take on this why
do you think that the lightning Network
didn't
I don't want to say like continue but
didn't sort of fulfill that idea of
moving ownership why do you think they
went down a different route
it may sound bizarre there but I think
our approach is too simple it's been
done before and people think can you
really just keep moving the ownership of
something right so if I said to you look
let's say cars were Commodities that
you'd never had to move and I said look
just take your keys around use that as
ownership of the car or take your
logbook or with a house take your deed
it it would be too simple to actually
take to its fullest degree so I really
think philosophically they got it wrong
it's been complicated from a development
perspective but the idea behind it is
actually quite simple
okay that's interesting and one thing
which a lot of people have um an issue
with when it comes to bitcoin is despite
it having this incredibly high level of
anonymity it's still not entirely
private because you know if I send you
one Bitcoin Russell you're gonna be able
to see how much Bitcoin I have in my
wallet you'll be able to see everything
that I've that I've ever done so I'm
curious does soft note make Bitcoin more
Anonymous or or maybe even more private
exactly that and I think you've picked
up on the fact later that because we're
using a passcode the only thing that's
recorded on that blockchain that
actually changes is that passcode
there's no sender details there's no
recipient details we're just changing
the state of let's say the access to
that particular soft load so
theoretically you could make thousands
of transactions using a soft node but
absolutely nobody will know that it was
you that did it because you just changed
a passcode and they wouldn't know who
you sent it to and a very interesting
recent issue I know you're a big
advocate of Andrew Tate and there's been
a few few articles that have come out
recently that believe that the Romanian
authorities actually track some of his
Bitcoin yeah
and we know some of it was confiscated
anyway and of course it seems as though
the evidence points towards the fact
that they did arrest them without
justification but because they were able
to track this data track this
information immediately a lot of
authorities presume that you're doing
something untoward and when there's
evidence to the country so the great
thing with the software is it does
actually increase that anonymity it
keeps all the security of Bitcoin it
keeps the decentralization but if you
want that Pure Freedom to spend your
money considering the visual money
however you want you get that anonymity
with the software I think that anonymity
is so important because like you
mentioned you know you brought up Andrew
take people just speaking facts
according to me um are getting you know
deep platforms canceled put in jail and
things like that and you know I always
say that money really is the center of
everything in life like it's it's the
it's the fuel which just it's the energy
which fuels your life and so you know if
you don't have control of your money you
don't have you know privacy you're just
not a sovereign individual and you're
just a slave to whatever you know
whatever comes so
um that's great to hear that this
obviously makes Bitcoin much more
private because in order to make Bitcoin
private obviously requires different
upgrades and this and that and it's you
start meddling with the actual software
itself which obviously you know people
people don't don't want to do would you
say that the lightning Network
um
has taken offer or would you say that
people are now more open to an
alternative solution
yeah I think people are really looking
for an alternative solution I mean
Michael sale is one of the biggest
advocates for the lightning Network you
can see post upon post of him supporting
any new layer 2 solution and he was
recently involved in the University
initiative whereby they were taking on
anybody who would work with Bitcoin and
had an idea as to how they can scale it
so I think the real problem layer is
what we needed with the lightning
network was for everybody to
interconnect if all these channels would
have been opened and people were happy
to connect with somebody let's say four
five seven different locations across
the world through different nodes then
it would have functioned perfectly but
uh you know the fact that you're shaking
your head so well people were against
that people really didn't want these
watch style assistants so they keep
going back to the native blockchain they
keep settling on the native blockchain
but Leia just to go back to that
previous point about and then yeah let's
do it a lot of people say look why do
you need the anonymity if you're not
doing anything that is untoward do you
really need to have that type of privacy
how would you come back to a Critic I
mean we've come across this ourselves
yes great question um I would give the
Edward Snowden response which is and I'm
and I'm going to paraphrase and not
quote correctly so I apologize but it's
something like um oh my God what is it
uh to say like you don't um you don't
want privacy because you have nothing to
hide is like saying you don't want
freedom of speech because you have
nothing to say that's what Edward
Snowden said and so that's my response
it's like what do you mean you have
nothing to hide what do you mean you
have nothing to say I think privacy is a
fundamental human right I don't think
anybody has a right to know what you're
up to in your life how much money you
have in your bank how much money you
have in your wallet I think it's a
fundamental human right
um and you know if people would like to
give up their privacy then I'm all for
that please do it and then go find out
what happens as a result of giving up
your privacy you know right yeah yeah
what would you say what would you say
yeah very similar it's a human right we
believe that people should have that
choice I mean look if somebody wants to
use a custodial wallet that's completely
up to them right if somebody wants to
know that AML is going to have their
hands all over any transactions over a
certain amount we know that's going to
change with cbdc's that's completely up
to them but cash was untracked and we
never had a problem with cash and we
believe that it was a human right to
have full access to your finances so
yeah would agree with that well just on
that point about cash
um I from what I've seen it's getting
harder and harder to spend your cash if
you notice that absolutely yeah
I mean
yeah
time and time again they've got to catch
the society they want to cash the
society and later give me your opinions
on why they want that why would you say
a government would want to cash this
oh my god well we'll we'll get into this
but I mean a cashless Society will it's
you're easier to control my take you
know for the people watching if they've
seen my content it's very much like
everything is about control because you
have to understand what are you
replacing cash with you're not replacing
it with like more Anonymous money no
you're replacing it with essential Bank
digital currency or for you're replacing
it with either like a brick coin a Fed
coin the digitally one
um and we'll get into cbdc's and
everything
um but I want to go back a little bit
actually to your topic about El Salvador
because part of what I do on social
media as well as talking about
um you know cbdc's and and and all the
uh and all the control that I believe is
coming
um I also want to get the word out there
about Bitcoin because I do believe it is
the answer to a lot of these issues and
I do believe that it is the hardest
money on the planet so I want to see it
Mass adopted so I'm curious how has
attacked him through its soft note
aiding Mass adoption I know obviously
you mentioned El Salvador before so can
anyone now have access to a soft note
and start sending Bitcoin privately and
anonymously instantly and almost
Fearless basically yeah absolutely look
shout out to our Dev team they've worked
tirelessly tirelessly for about six
years and they've got it to a point
where it's fully functioning we've got
people minting soft notes at the moment
we've actually had over a million this
last week of soft notes minted people
are sending them about the system
theoretically is fully functional so the
way we're approaching Mass adoption
layer is we want to get it in the hands
of everybody I noticed in your book you
stated that Bitcoin solves a lot of
human humanitarian issues people who
don't have access to banking facilities
people who can't get on the financial
ladder because of where they were born
or who they were born to the soft note
eradicates all of that as long as you've
got internet access and theoretically
you don't even need that because you can
transfer that serial number over the
phone you can get into the software
system now we recently signed up we ran
a bit of a pilot scheme and we signed up
10 Merchants to accept soft notes so
theoretically there's a market for it
people want to accept these they see
that you utility in it as soon as that's
built out and we've got our POS system
coming in about two months as soon as
that's fully functional we expect to see
people starting to spend that and
because we're not bound to this web3
environment because it is just a
passcode that gets you access to that
Bitcoin we don't see any bounds of the
soft note system of course it comes down
to how well it's marketed who takes it
on board but as soon as people realize
the utility We Believe Mass adoption
could be just around the corner we
actually recently ran a hackathon and we
asked as many people to come to our
system and find issues and they did
great they found bugs and they were
really helpful bugs that we've been able
to address but nobody's found a
fundamental flaw in how the system is
working at the moment so that of course
gave us great confidence to say let's
get it out there let's get some good
exposure let's get launched and try to
bring Mass adoption around to the
Bitcoin world I completely agree with
you it's the best currency out there
it's the currency that we should trust
it's still the test of time and part of
what we're saying Leia is we're not
asking you to trust our blockchain we
have to demonstrate that we have to
prove that our blockchain won't be
hacked but because you can get out of
our blockchain with the click of the
button theoretically you're still
trusting Bitcoin you're just using us as
exactly what we say we are a layer two
to be able to move it above
that's so interesting and one of the
things which um I didn't know which I I
just learned um was the idea that you
don't need um internet because you can
just send a series you can send a serial
number over the phone that's that's
crazy can you tell me more about that
yeah absolutely so as we were talking
about earlier the soft note is just a
serial number and a passcode so that
then gives you access to be able to burn
your Bitcoin if you want but if you just
want to transfer that ownership that
serial number at the moment is about 16
digits you can give somebody a call give
them that serial number give them that
passcode and that means that they fully
own the access now they don't even need
to keep it in that system they don't
have to keep it written down they can
take it online they can use our own
wallet system they can go off wallet but
it gives them the full utility to use it
however however they want so let's say
hypothetically you've got banned from
the internet you couldn't get access to
the internet that's not the end of the
soft note system I understand that's so
interesting and what would you say your
big vision for soft notes is and
particularly in terms of acceptability
um I know you said you'd be speaking to
some Merchants but what's the overall
Big Goal would you like to be in
countries like El Salvador yeah
absolutely we believe as soon as we
demonstrate the utility and this is
exactly how Bitcoin grew right it
demonstrated the utility with those
people who were purists those people who
wanted to try out the system they saw
the necessity for the system but it
wasn't the big corporations and to a
certain degree still isn't they get on
board with Bitcoin it was those people
who really believed in the vision and
what we want to do is expand our product
to everybody who believes in the vision
and once the let's say merchants or the
government see the utility and of course
those governments have really believe in
Freedom for for the individual as soon
as they see that utility we believe that
they will be taking it on if it was El
Salvador if the softenerate system was
there I'm absolutely sure it would still
be fully functioning and have you come
into any regulatory issues or any you
know government issues because like I
said you're making Bitcoin much more
Anonymous sorry private than it was
before
yeah so there's two sides to that coin
layer firstly we have absolutely we've
got to deal with the am L issues we've
got to deal with the kyc issues and it
goes back to the point that you raised
earlier we're going to give people an
option we've got our on wallet solution
that is AML compliant that is kyc
compliant the blockchain is being built
up to be completely decentralized so all
we do is we create a wallet whereby you
can have all the buyer protection you
need just like you would at paper you
can have all the safety you need but
really the utility is when you either
take it off wallet or you use our
decentralized option which is called
Soft note swap it's essentially
decentralized wallet that functions with
soft nodes so you have a choice between
the three on the on wallet system of
course we are complying with AML we are
complying with kyc that's because we're
offering buyer protection and we see
this as an essential route to getting
Mass adoption you're not going to get
the people who don't really believe in
Bitcoin to use Bitcoin unless there's
some familiarity if you can give them by
protection if you can give them AML
they're more likely to come into the
system try it see the great utility of
soft nodes see the great utility of
Bitcoin and then say I'll try it in a
more decentralized manner let me see if
I see the utility there as well
yeah no that that makes a lot of sense
and I want to go back to what we spoke
about earlier um and I guess this does
lead on from um you know all the
benefits of the soft note I do want to
touch on cbdc's because I think this is
something that I've spoken about a lot
um on Fox News GB news in the UK um and
you know personally I just don't think
people understand just how quickly they
will come and also just how dangerous
they're going to be
um you know I've given you my take
partly and we can get into my taking a
little bit more in a minute but I'm
curious to hear your take especially
because I think uh the bank of England
actually just hired or are assembling a
team of 30 crypto experts to build a
cbdc so what what is your take on
Central Bank digital currencies I mean
huge topic I think there's a lot to get
through here the first thing I'd say
about cbdc's is they're not what were
promised to us originally when we heard
about cbdc's originally when countries
were first looking at cbdc we were told
they were going to be blockchain
projects we were told they would be
centralized but they would be an
immutable Ledger that means you'll
always be able to see what's going on
and that's typically not what's happened
and the interesting thing is I think
cbdc's at the moment are demonstrating a
hinge point in society that we've never
seen before and what I mean by that is I
think because we've got to a
technological Point whereby tyranny can
be implemented if somebody's so desired
we've got to make personal choices and
to kind of Flesh this out later if I
said to you
we all prioritize human flourishing we
all prioritize human advantage and being
as healthy and happy as possible if I
asked you what did you think were the
main three industries that could have an
influence on human flourishing what
would you say
oh
that's a great question
um
well I mean crypto personally would be
like my number one just because as I
said I think that money is the center of
everything and if you don't if you don't
have money then you know you're screwed
basically you're forever you know a
slave to the government
um I haven't thought about the other two
I mean like could I say like crypto and
like Fitness the fitness industry
um and then and then like health and
nutrition perhaps I don't know what
would you say
yeah I would start right at the top I'd
say philosophy religion spirituality
you've got to understand I have a theory
of why you're here to know your person
the second absolutely medicine and
health and then I would say the third
was finances but what we're noticing in
society if we start right at the top
everything's centered now you can't have
a religious perspective you can't have a
philosophical perspective you can't have
your own perspective even on things like
family and gender if we go one step down
we saw everything that happened
throughout covid with regards to the
medical industry and so something
fascinating about the medical industry
is seven years of med school teaches you
what to think not how to think and what
I'm Blown Away by is the way the medical
professionals are actually still in
defense they were the first ones to
stand in defense of the Nazi regime and
they were the first ones to stand in
defense of everything that was rolled
out through Kobe so we've seen this
great shift in those two industries and
I believe this is the last one to put
full control on all of those three
Industries so you can take away the
ability for a human to obtain human
flourishing so if you can control
somebody's finances you can then control
what they do health-wise medically wise
and you can also control what they
believe but if you can find some way to
liberate yourself to completely control
your finances you are free to do
whatever you want with your body
health-wise and you're also free
religiously philosophically spiritually
and even from an ethical perspective to
believe and say whatever you are
I think that was put so well
um you know and and I agree with you um
and I always give this same example you
know I say during
um you know the last three years with
with that flu that went around
um yeah that crazy flu
um you know I always say you know if you
didn't take the Jib Jab and if cbdcs
were
um implemented at that point they would
have programmed the money so that you
could only spend it on certain items so
exactly like you're saying where you
control the money you're able to control
the three pillars of of your version of
Happiness so you know food is one of
them and so yes when you control the
money you can control what people eat
and another thing as well is
um those are the world economic Forum
they you know they want us to eat bugs
basically like there's a war on on
masculinity
because it is war meat and you know they
say that meat is bad for you and and you
know the more meat you eat the more the
planet's gonna die and whatever if you
eat meat your right wing bigger and all
this stuff so you just program the money
so that people aren't allowed to buy so
much meat right that's the way I look at
it I say okay well they want to
implement a carbon allowance how do you
do that through the money so say you you
know you you bought a bunch of burgers
or whatever or you filled up your car
when you go and buy the burgers you've
reached your carbon allowance and then
it gets
now we will have to eat bugs you know
what I mean yeah absolutely I mean there
was a study recently that was Associated
the world with the worldly government
forum and they said this which is really
quite astounding they said the number
one benefit of cbdcs to the individual
user or the average civilian is that you
no longer have to file your taxes
so the government can just take your
taxes that's crazy think about how much
information they have to accumulate to
be able to work out exactly how much
that's amazing where did you see that I
want to write that down so I can look it
up yeah I'll get you over the documents
of the world economic Forum will
publishing okay I'm gonna just write
that down why do you can wait for him
okay cool wow and you know that's so
interesting but you know it's so funny
it's like the world would be a much
better place if um we had full
transparency so we were able to see
where their money went where our tax
dollars or Pounds or whatever you know
where our taxes went we don't have we
don't have access to that but of course
like all relationships with the
government it's going to be entirely
one-sided so they're able to see
everything that we have ever done but
we're unable to see everything that
they've done and you know how our tax
dollars are being spent on Wars and and
so on and so on yeah absolutely I mean
the fascinating thing is through our
history the role of government has been
to protect those who are feeble benefit
those or reward those who do well and
punish those who do wrong that's got
nothing to do with finances that's got
nothing to do with controlling your free
speech it's got nothing to do with what
you believe and throughout those three
layers that we spoke about I think we've
seen the government go far beyond their
actual bounds far beyond their actual
responsibilities and we're by no means
anti-government the government is so
essential for Law and Order I mean I've
spoken to you later you love Dubai you
love everything that's going on in Miami
there's a reason for that the government
are doing a great job but when the
government goes beyond what their bounds
are for example into finances it's the
humans responsibility to create a system
that can combat that and that's what we
believe we're doing with soft notes so
essentially if you stay in Bitcoin
everybody talks about Bitcoin as a store
of value it only really becomes a
circulating currency on a layer two and
if that layer two is a scalable and
expansive as a soft node then you
essentially get that freedom from the
government if they would where they have
going beyond their bounds
you know what's pretty interesting to me
um before we obviously went live and you
know we had this conversation you were
sort of saying yeah you know I'm happy
to discuss all sorts of things and
that's the refreshing and I love that
but I'm curious because it's quite
unique I often find a lot of people who
are building things
um you know who are like CEOs of
companies and so on are often quite
uncomfortable talking about different
social issues or speaking about these
things so I love that you know you're
you're really open about it um so so how
comes like like what makes you what
makes you different in that sense yeah I
like it how come you're so different in
that sense I mean if you met our team
layer you would get it we're all okay in
mindset we all have this very similar
ideologies we've made similar choices
and that's what's drawn us to this
project this is why we've developed this
project because it is the case that we
believe that you need to have Financial
Freedom it is the case that we believe
that essentially without that Financial
Freedom you work up those three tiers
and you get about and the reason why
we're happy to be so open about these
things is because we we don't believe
that we're actually going beyond the way
history has functioned for so long we're
just saying we need to go back to the
point where we have Liberty we're
pro-government we're pro- control we do
not support Anarchy but we are a
pro-human liberty and so yeah I mean I
think a lot of CEOs would avoid the
topic because
I guess they've got a lot to lose in the
current industry that they're in but the
soft note is for the libertarian and if
you're not a Libertarian you're probably
not going to love yourself
I respect that I love that I think that
makes so much sense I see so many
amazing companies in the space shy away
from these kind of issues and I'm like
do not know who your audience is your
audience like your customers want this
like this is they want you to be of that
similar mindset um and I think as well
it helps it helps people
um
develop like trust with you and
understand you and and realize you know
your mission is this is the same as
theirs um you know and I think that's
like a huge win for people like Elon
Musk for example because obviously you
know he's taken over Twitter and he he's
doing a great job he's calling out all
sorts of rubbish I mean did you see the
interview that he did with the BBC
yesterday brilliant absolutely brilliant
so yeah our co-founder send that over to
me and okay yeah all you're doing is
calling out the truth but it's so
counter-cultural yes the reaction was
just disbelief yeah absolutely
absolutely it was really crazy so no I I
commend you for being so open and I
think that it's um you know it's going
to be a net positive protect him in the
future absolutely
um I want to get your take on the
markets actually Bitcoin is pumping
we're at thirty thousand dollars
um which kind of upsets me because I
feel like I still didn't stack enough
and either
yeah I do feel that way
um but what is your take with the market
right now do you think we're finally
seeing a decoupling of Bitcoin from the
general financial markets
yeah I think that's exactly what we're
seeing and there are numerous
perspectives from economists about
exactly what's happened with Bitcoin
over the last two three months of course
we've heard a lot of fear-mongering
about the uh General stock markets
dropping property dropping and we have
actually seen that whether we've seen
the bottom of it and how far that's
going to go it depends on which side of
the coin you land and of course there
are those who are also saying it's a
completely fabricated recession we've
also seen some of the biggest oil
companies tripling their prices but
tripling their profits so people are
pointing to the fact that that can't
make sense economically so my hypothesis
is as things currently stand and you
highlighted this in your book layer as
soon as the government pushes harder
people push back as soon as the
government implements more financial
control more people get into Bitcoin and
I think we're seeing the decentralized
currencies doing a little bit better
than the non
decentralized uh centralized
cryptocurrency
so I think that's just conducive with
the fact that people are saying we can
no longer trust the USD we can no longer
trust fiat currency what's the most
trustable option outside of that so I
don't think these are Big Risk Takers I
think they're people who are saying
Bitcoin stood the test of time bitcoin's
been absolutely resilient nobody's had
Bitcoin if I'm not using a fiat currency
that hinges on supposed government trust
I'm going to go for the most trusted
cryptocurrency and we all know Bitcoin
leads that run so I think exactly what
we're seeing is people wanting to get
into that so as to be involved in
something that has great longevity but
also avoids all the pitfalls of the
current Fiat system yeah I agree and I
think that that is something that I push
a lot the idea of of if the government
becomes more authoritarian and you know
increasing its control then people will
wake up I mean I know just so many
people were so orange pilled during
during covid um I I know so many people
that turned to bitcoin during that time
um you know what happened in Canada with
with Justin Trudeau and the truckers I
know that orange killed a lot of people
um even just even just a lot of people
in England because England from my
experience you can obviously tell me if
you feel the same I feel is often quite
behind
when it comes to Innovation and Tech and
so many people in England finally
understood Bitcoin when Justin Trudeau
froze people's bank accounts for
protesting the rights to their own body
um so absolutely I agree with you I
think you know the more authoritarian it
becomes the more the more people run to
bitcoin and then on top of that as well
I thought the usdc
um I thought the usdc uh d-peg was
really fascinating and I actually spoke
about this on my spaces um and I was
holding usdc I hold many different coins
um USBC was one of them and it was a
Friday night I was in Florida and it's a
Friday night and I was out and I looked
at my phone and I was like oh my God I'm
down 10 like why is my goodness
right and I'm there just like out and
worried and concerned and so I ended up
you know asking myself what do I do do I
like where do I put the money to
um prevent a potential lunar
catastrophic result yeah um what does
anyone doing situations right you you
say okay what like what could I do I
have to move the money now into the
easiest thing that I can access
and the safest thing that I have access
to yeah the only answer to that is
Bitcoin I'm not going to turn it to cash
can't do that not going to like move it
into a bank it's too difficult right now
just simple swap to bitcoin is is really
the only solution
um and it's to me personally I feel like
that's what what sort of sparked this
this run yeah it's fascinating to I
think it's probably the first time in
history that we can say Bitcoin has
officially decoupled from the general
stocks markets it's going upwards
they're going down it's we're in a
supposed recession economists say in a
recession people take less risks and I
think that's completely true you're
actually taking less of a risk when you
go for Bitcoin now and I think the
principle stands true but actually
Bitcoin is is essentially stating that
it's going to be a separate entity from
what the General market does because
it's offering something totally
different to what the market does
exactly
um and also I'm just curious can you
tell me a little bit about your
background in crypto I know you say
you've been developing
um you know the soft note for quite a
few years now how long have you been in
crypto
so yeah really interesting question and
very similar to your experience so I
know you stated in your book that you
had a certain amount of fiat currency
Frozen I had a very similar experience
and it was frozen for the amount of time
that it would make incredible
complications and this was all on the
basis of absolutely no evidence
absolutely no data the money was then
released quite a few months later with
no apology no understanding that they
didn't do their due diligence and all
throughout that time I was stood there
saying that's my money you can't take my
money away but the fact of the matter is
they could and they did and that
propelled me more so into crypto I was
always in crypto I loved crypto and I
was I've got a medical background so I
was working in r d at the time and it
then caused me to look for employment
inside the web through space and it was
that that brought me across to this
project when the project was uh I guess
in its infancy stages with regards to
off note and it's the thing that drives
me here it drives all of us the idea
that we can have full Liberty but more
so that we can give Financial Liberty to
the world and because the soft note
accomplishes that it gives everybody the
chance if they want to to avoid that
situation that you went through Leia and
the situation that I went through that
became the driving factor to be in the
space
actually that's similar to me um yeah
the the financial Liberty to the world
because I remember when I was first
learning about blockchain technology
um quite a few years ago and I just
loved the idea that you didn't need a
bank account and anyone anywhere in the
world as long as they have internet
access can you know get involved um you
know and it also it also like opens up
the global um economy because when I'm
doing
business with different people I'm not
just doing business with Americans or
Brits I now have access to people all
over the world who who can make
themselves much more competitive
financially to the people who are in my
own country
um and you know I just pay them in
crypto and now we have this global
economy where everybody
um is put on the financial map and
personally I just I I just love that
yeah I mean Leia look I loved your Tweet
when you spoke about the person you
hired in Pakistan yeah exactly you're
right for about a fifth of what you were
going to pay in the USA yeah everybody
talks about equality of opportunity and
you've got numerous people on the right
to use an American term constantly
espousing equality of opportunity
there's no quicker way to pull down the
barriers of a quality of opportunity
than Bitcoin of course we've got to
scale it that's why we think we are the
solution for that but if you want to
give everybody a chance most people have
an internet connection these days most
people have a phone if you want to give
that intellect that happened to be born
in South Mongolia and never gets a
chance to go to university but he's a
very talented kid you need to enable him
to be able to spend money receive money
in a way that doesn't bind him to some
of the centralized systems absolutely
and it's so funny because it's like a
lot of the time these people who um who
demand equality of outcome are the very
people who hate Bitcoin so much and it's
like what do you mean we're literally
we're literally leveling the playing
field here we're doing the very thing
you want well
exactly
um so what else do you have planned
um for tectum
so we are currently embarking on our
launch we've got our pre-sale that is
currently running but it's only running
for a few more days on our website so
you can get the token the token gives
you access to Mint soft nodes of course
you don't have to do that and you
pointed out there are people who are
just going to want to get a soft note
send a soft note use the soft node they
don't want to get involved in the whole
ecosystem they don't have to do that but
the token allows you to mince off notes
it allows you to provide liquidity once
you've minted and provided liquidity
There's an actual reward system that
functions in all of that when a soft
node makes fees and we're only charging
the merchant when as as things currently
stand we're not charging the end user
that's our plan to get Mass adoption
going so you are sending soft notes for
free but as soon as it goes through a
retail environment we're charging the
merchant up to about 0.75 so in more
competitive than all the other Payment
Solutions out there but rewards are then
brought back to the person that minted
the soft node so the reason why we've
got a million soft nodes already minted
on our system is because we've got these
purists that absolutely love the project
and they've gone ahead and minted them
but they're getting them out to people
who don't care about minsing they're not
interested in providing liquidity they
just want to utilize the system so as
things currently stand that pre-sale is
going on we've got a couple of CeX
listings that are going to come next
month or the month after prior to that
we've also got a pink sale listing and a
lot of people have said was pink sale
the platform that suited techton the
most but it goes back to what we were
talking about later the decentralized
industries are absolutely booming at the
moment everybody's wanting to get into
that system whereby they no longer have
to trust a third-party entity and pink
cell does that so well of course you get
a lot of poor coins on there but pink
cell is absolutely thriving for the best
project so we're going down the Dex
route pink cell then perhaps it's going
to be uni Swap and then we're going to
look at the other cexs and we have
actually signed some contracts for that
so it's all about our launch at the
moment bringing people towards the
project and getting soft notes into the
hands of the people
so how can people stay up to date and
follow everything that's going on with
the launch
so the best way to do that is probably
our Twitter and our website you can find
both of those in the link our website's
constantly updated with blog articles
our Twitter is also in the description
below but do hop into our telegram group
one of the great things about our
telegram group is so many of our
initiatives have been Community Driven
so people get on there they ask
questions they give us ideas and
straight away we bring them back to the
decision makers and the team and we can
Implement your suggestions so because
we're building the system for the
community we want the community
involvement so yeah do hop into there
and give us your thoughts on everything
that we're doing
that's amazing I'm gonna leave all of
that information
um in the YouTube description so I'll
leave the link to the telegram and and
the website and everything else that you
mentioned um in the description
um well Russell is there anything else
you would you'd like to add or do you do
for like we covered anything is there
anything else you you want to add before
I wrap up Yeah final question to you
later
yes currently bitcoin's the store of
value
and they it was a fascinating
conversation I had with somebody from
the Cato Institute are you familiar with
the keto Institute no I'm not okay so
they follow CPAC around the
conservatives uh style conference you
get the Ben ship Heroes there and
they're on the financial side of things
and it was quite a big VC that we were
having a conversation with and he's been
very pro-bitcoin up until now and we
were pitching our product to him and he
essentially turned to me and said
Russell give up
you're not going to beat the USD
Bitcoin is never going to get to the
position where you want it to and the
best thing to do is to get on board with
these cbdc's but just try and make them
as transparent as possible now my
question to you then later is
if at the moment the circulating supply
of Bitcoin is so low what do you see the
solution being
well I mean it's divisible right so and
I think that's a great thing it's it's
divisible we can all have 0.00 whatever
have have a thousand satoshi's or
whatever it is one Satoshi could become
one dollar
um and I think that's a good thing it
means that the money is more is more
scarce like we I don't want something
with such a large circulating Supply I
know of course this is like a really big
controversial topic I've had people
debate this before but you know I don't
want something with such a large
circulating Supply
um the fact that we have this limited
Supply will will mean that we're
transacting with a currency which will
increase in value rather than devalue
like the US dollar and you know I really
disagree with this idea of you can't win
so you can't beat them so you might as
well join them I mean it's just such a
defeated mentality I just don't support
that in the slightest and I also am very
aware that
um cbdc's will never be transparent and
they will never be fair and they will be
the Spy coin they will be an
authoritarian um Force for for bad and
so I I think that we should
give every bit of our energy to creating
things which beat them or which compete
with them I I definitely don't agree
with oh we can't we can't beat them so
just bow down and join them
so Leia tell me how do you think we did
at undressing the software
oh I think you did a great job and I
love that you read my book thank you so
much I noticed you really did read it
you really did give it up yeah you
really did read it
um no I think I think you did a great
job it's really interesting and um no
I'm excited I'm excited about everything
that you have coming up simply because
you know I I do believe in Bitcoin I
just don't necessarily believe in the
lightning Network um I did obviously
write in the book that
um there are issues and I think it's
going to be very difficult to be Mass
adopted like you said people don't want
to be opening up a million different
channels
um and so yeah like we need we need a
scaling solution you know we need we
need something which allows Bitcoin to
be able to be transacted instantly so
that it can really become that Global
medium of exchange and if soft note is
the answer then then that's great
um and you know so I'm personally going
to be um catching up with you very soon
because I because I want to know I want
to know what's happening I want to see
Bitcoin adoption as soon as possible
absolutely brilliant fascinating to talk
yeah Russell thank you so much for
coming on the show guys thank you all so
much for watching definitely go check
out um tectum I'm really fascinated to
see whether they will
um be the ultimate Bitcoin scaling
solution
um I think that's gonna be really
interesting and if you did enjoy this
kind of content then please don't forget
to hit the like button and subscribe
because we will be covering more of this
and obviously we'll be bringing Russell
back to get an update um in a few weeks
so Russell thank you so much for coming
on the show and um we will see you all
next week bye